[Música]
bienvenidos una vez más a reporteros
gracias por estar con nosotros
turquía es un país que se debate entre
la herencia profundamente secular de su
fundador mustafa kemal atatürk y la
religión estatal que ahora promueve el
presidente recep tayip erdogán el
gobierno está tratando de imponer sus
puntos de vista mediante la presión
psicológica y un plan de estudios
educativos revisado minuciosamente pero
hay una fuerte resistencia
erdogán que llegó a la política nacional
en el año 2002 ha construido centenares
de mezquitas ha fomentado el desarrollo
de escuelas religiosas públicas y ha
convertido a santa sofía el símbolo de
estambul en un lugar de culto musulmán a
pesar de esto los fundamentos kemalistas
siguen existiendo salvio en este momento
hay una batalla aria ella es autora de
este reportaje jonah gracias por estar
con nosotros esta imposición del islam
es algo que usted observó durante la
realización de este reportaje
y es si de hecho es algo difícil de
identificar
a nosotros nos tomó más de 4 meses poder
mostrarlo en este reportaje y poner todo
junto y eso es porque nosotros no
tuvimos manera de filmar dentro o algo
relacionado con estas escuelas y maneja
tips
nuestras escuelas son públicas y
musulmanas y de hecho el director de la
escuela el ministro de educación e
incluso la asociación de exalumnos
responden positivamente a nuestras
solicitudes de entrevistas y todavía
hasta ahora no han ocurrido y esto es
precisamente algo muy común que ocurre
aquí en turquía y como periodista es
imposible acceder a una entrevista con
una fuente oficial y luego los
periodistas están acusados de estar
sesgados y claro que lo estarán si
tienen dificultades de ser neutrales y
todos los involucrados de la historia se
niegan a hablar con el invitados
entonces a ver el siguiente reportaje
[Música]
desde el 24 de julio santa sofía es una
mezquita y osman está muy feliz por esto
[Música]
mi trabajo está justo al lado de la
halla sofía así que asiste a la primera
oración del viernes en la plaza
luego visite el interior de la mezquita
allá sofía quería ver este lugar como
una mezquita la visité antes cuando era
un museo y fue triste fue una
experiencia triste para mí creo que para
mucha gente por mí
fue un gran símbolo para la conquista
también para la existencia musulmán en
la ciudad
etc
osman su felicidad quisiera incluso que
el recinto estuviera reservado
exclusivamente a los musulmanes no me
gusta cuando veo a la gente deambulando
por ahí como si visitara una playa o
cualquier lugar turístico no es un lugar
turístico es un lugar importante para
los musulmanes y su historia lo
demuestra
en un mismo y el espacio dedicado a la
oración es muy pequeño no es compatible
con el espíritu de allá sofía creo
entiendo la emoción de la gente si es
algo bueno quieren verla pero no de esa
manera
nata reactivo
durante mil años santa sofía fue la
mayor iglesia del mundo antes de
convertirse en mezquita cuando los
otomanos conquistaron constantinopla en
1453 cinco siglos después
mustafa kemal atatürk la convirtió en un
museo
[Música]
esta decisión no fue aceptada no fue
considerado como podemos separar al
turco de musulmán no no podemos que no
importa la motivación de erdogán
y aprecio plenamente
en general
al final por supuesto el islam ganarán
de identidad religiosa identidad
nacional estas dos naciones son una y la
misma en los mensajes del presidente 19
años en el poder son de una generación y
es a esta nueva generación a la que
quiere impregnar de religión nos dice
sanz musaví númer singh
que está armándose le mans
tan fácil
15 quien eres es el título de este vídeo
producido por el a cape el partido
presidencial enumera las figuras
históricas espirituales e intelectuales
que se supone que forjan en carácter y
la identidad de la juventud turca la
mayoría son hombres muchos de ellos
vinculados a la tradición musulmana
todos se encarnan en la figura de un
hombre creyente tayyip erdogán
les brindaban geithner del yen
entre los personajes elegidos para guiar
a los jóvenes no hay ninguno que no sea
musulmán ni tampoco figuras laicas
atatürk queda relegado a un segundo
plano lo que representa un crimen de
lesa majestad para esta asociación que
defiende la memoria del fundador de la
república de turquía
intentan que olvidemos atatürk intentan
quitarnos a nuestro atatürk intentan
deshacerse del laicismo en turquía hay
una masa de gente que es kemalista laica
democrática y que no cambiará nuestra
esencia desata turk y nadie podrá
cambiar nuestra esencia entonces uno se
cansa de estar más
feliz es la presidenta de la rama local
de esta asociación nacional en esmirna
lleva atrás las huellas del que fue
apodado el padre de los turcos quiere
creer que el legado de su héroe sigue
siendo relevante hoy en día el interés
de los jóvenes por el kemalismo aumenta
día a día porque ellos también son
conscientes de la importancia de la
modernidad del sistema republicano del
laicismo
farc en dallas en el calendario turco
cuatro de los nueve días festivos están
directamente relacionados con atatürk
sus retratos siguen exhibiéndose en
todas partes y es quizás en la costa del
egeo donde los vestigios de su culto a
la personalidad son todavía más visibles
aquí como en el resto del país el
aniversario de su muerte se conmemora
con un minuto de silencio respetado
fervorosamente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
para la ocasión se reunieron los
directivos mayores de la asociación a
quienes los une una admiración sin
límites hacia el padre de la patria no
pueden quitarnos lo nadie podrá borrar
atatürk el aniversario de su muerte es
simplemente un recordatorio de que es
inmortal es solo su cuerpo el que ya no
existe lo que pienso es que nunca he
visto su cuerpo pero cuando escuchó su
voz mis ojos se llenan de lágrimas no
escucho su voz se me pone la piel de
gallina
atatürk y significa turquía y turquía
significa turk es un gran líder un líder
histórico atatürk es una bendición un
regalo de alá todopoderoso para la
nación turca y por eso todo lo que hizo
tuvo éxito
estos guardianes del templo kemalista
están convencidos de que al querer hacer
una turquía más musulmana
el actual presidente destruiría los
logros feministas de atatürk
eso es irrefutable eso sí hoy soy libre
si puedo respirar si pueden ver de aquí
las gracias hasta turquía nadie más
15 6 y nunca podré entender a las
mujeres que cuestionan en su comunicado
estudiaba atatürk sigue siendo una
figura tutelar insultar su memoria puede
ser motivo de encarcelamiento sin
embargo sus retratos tienden a
desaparecer de las paredes de algunas
escuelas
[Música]
esta es la escuela pública recep tayyip
erdogán de estambul una escuela imam
afip donde se le da prioridad a la
religión
en su juventud el propio presidente
ardón asistió aquí por lo que fue
rebautizada en su honor y renovada con
una ayuda de 9 millones de euros estas
imágenes son parte de un vídeo
promocional ni la dirección de la
escuela ni el ministerio de educación
respondieron a nuestras numerosas
solicitudes de entrevista en cuanto al
plan de estudios en los centros de
enseñanza secundaria en manatí
por ejemplo cuando vemos los cursos que
se imparten durante la semana
aproximadamente una cuarta parte
exactamente el 26 por ciento de esos
cursos son optativos que en realidad se
han convertido en obligatorios pero en
realidad estas asignaturas optativas son
cursos relacionados con el islam sunita
y sí que es investigadora y se
especializa en los imán a tipo ha visto
cómo se han multiplicado desde la
llegada al poder de hereje tayyip
erdogán aunque en un principio estos
establecimientos eran frecuentados por
estudiantes destinados a convertirse en
imanes el presidente ahora quiere que
asistan a ellos el mayor número posible
de estudiantes
el hecho de que no se haya considerado a
otros grupos religiosos o confesional es
un derecho similar a tener sus propias
escuelas
indica que el estado no es imparcial ya
que sólo existe en este tipo de escuelas
para el islam sunita
sainz y creemos la mica de chilonché
puede decir que los máximos años el
presidente de la república ha elogiado a
menudo esta base de la cndh o control de
la base de interés
según las cifras del ministerio de
educación el estado paga más dinero por
alumno a estas escuelas que a otras sin
embargo la mayoría de los antiguos
alumnos revisados en una encuesta dicen
que se arrepienten de haber estudiado
allí la ocde considera que el nivel de
educación es inferior al de las escuelas
laicas las cuales no se libran del deseo
del presidente de imponer sus ideas aquí
ya no se enseña la teoría de la
evolución sin embargo es en las escuelas
donde el laicismo se resiste el propio
presidente tuvo que admitirlo
creo que si evaluamos francamente los
últimos 18 años
hemos hecho un progreso histórico en
todas las áreas pero en las áreas de la
educación y la cultura no hemos podido
progresar con mejorías juniors
tenemos una población joven gracias a
dios ambos estamos aplicando plenamente
en nuestra visión civilizatoria y de
hecho cada vez más jóvenes turcos
rechazan los preceptos religiosos lo que
la prensa llama el fenómeno de ista
es decir un islam personal oa la carta
algunos van más allá e incluso se llaman
a sí mismos ateos como mesut y llegan
[Música]
para nosotros ser ateo es una mentalidad
que rechaza a los dioses y las ilusiones
mantente una mentalidad que rechaza esto
y que consiste en vivir según sus
propias verdades una mentalidad que
aprecia a la humanidad
para mí ser ateo y sobre todo libertad
es vivir cuestionando y buscando la
verdad sin estar
según una encuesta de 2019 el número de
jóvenes que se consideran religiosos ha
descendido un 7% desde 2008 pero asumir
su ateísmo tiene un precio
trabajé en un lugar casi seis años hasta
que me volví ateo nunca había tenido
problemas con mi pago ni nada porque
porque en ese momento todavía era
musulmán pero en cuanto me volví ateo a
partir del pasado mes de febrero me
bajaron el salario que era digamos 2500
liras turcas a 1500 liras y al mes
siguiente a medidas mi familia es
extremadamente conservadora
mi padre incluso hizo la peregrinación a
la meca dio la vuelta a la cava pero no
se puede cambiar la mentalidad de la
gente de ninguna manera y la presión es
así expulsión de la familia separación
de los amigos o del cónyuge es una
presión psicológica
aunque recep tayyip erdogán fue elegido
primero por musulmanes conservadores que
se sentían denigrados por su religión
hoy los hijos de estos quieren definir
su propia relación con el islam
muchos de estos mismos jóvenes votarán
por primera vez en las próximas
elecciones de 2023
[Música]
jona gracias por su reportaje y de hecho
claramente hay dos versiones de lo que
turquía debería ser y le pregunto si
estas dos miradas pueden reconciliarse
hoy no realmente hay una verdadera
división en la sociedad turca por un
lado hay una visión y un estilo de vida
más secular más europeo por lo menos más
abierta a esa parte del mundo y hay otro
sector de identidad turca que tiene sus
raíces en la religión musulmana y ve el
islam como un pilar central de turquía
hoy es esta investigadora con la que
hablamos en el reporte nos dio
información más detallada de esta
identidad turca
en las escuelas y mam jatif así como en
las escuelas que llamamos normales hay
clases de valores nacionales morales
espirituales la mayoría de las veces
estos valores nacionales reflejan
valores turcos a costa de los valores
universales e ignoran las perspectivas
de otros grupos étnicos y los valores
espirituales son en su mayoría
religiosos
joana y le pregunto ahora si encontró
algo que pueda cambiar la visión del
país
bueno las próximas elecciones están
previstas para 2023 y tiene dos años o
más para lograr su visión pero en los
últimos diecinueve desde que llegó al
poder hemos visto lo opuesto en la
sociedad turca luchaste nada drástico
pero definitivamente notable de acuerdo
a una encuesta de 2019 el 34% de las
mujeres turcas se cubren la cabeza en
contraste con el 37 por ciento diez años
antes ese mismo estudio dice que 65% de
los turcos actuales ayunar en ramadán
contra 77% hace una década
y estos números no sólo reflejan a los
jóvenes sino a todas las edades estos
cambios son aparentes a pesar de las por
lo menos 12.000 mezquitas construidas
por el presidente desde que llegó al
poder en 2002 a pesar de la conversión
de hagia sofía y otros museos anteriores
iglesias en mezquitas y por supuesto a
pesar de las inversiones que hemos visto
en la educación en estas escuelas
religiosas públicas musulmanas
erdogán tiene una nueva carta una nueva
constitución en la que trabaja
actualmente que él espera lo ayude a
mantenerse en el poder dios
gracias de nuevo por acompañarnos en la
emisión de este reportaje recuerde que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web
france24 punto com para ver esta emisión
y las anteriores hasta la próxima semana